[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imaginez si vous avez des problèmes de
fertilité
jusqu'où iriez vous pour devenir parents
seriez vous prêt à accepter que votre
enfant ne soit pas votre enfant
biologique
seriez vous prêt axa adopter les enfants
plus vieux avec une culture différente
de la vôtre ou seriez-vous prêt à tenter
des traitements comme la fécondation in
vitro
moi j'ai dit oui à tout ça et j'ai eu la
chance de réaliser mon rêve d'être maman
pour mon mari et moi elle parle de bulle
et mais nos enfants et en prendre soin
notre famille correspondant à notre
définition du mot famille par contre
c'est pour nous être parent aurait voulu
dire avant le même mais ça que nos
enfants notre famille aujourd'hui
ressemblerait plus à ça sûrement
construit heureux quand même mais nous
de 13 ans avoir des enfants
pour le réaliser on a dû sortir de la
zone de confort et apprendre beaucoup
sur nous mêmes
quand mon mari et moi on a appris la
nouvelle que mâcon avait des problèmes
de fertilité
en fait mon mari était stérile à ce
moment là on ne savait pas encore
jusqu'où on était prêt à aller pour
devenir parents on l'a découvert au
cours de notre histoire vous si vous
appreniez que vous pourriez pas avoir
des enfants de façon naturelle
est ce que vous le savez voir quel
chemin vous auriez pour devenir parents
nous le premier qu'on a tenté c'est
celui d insémination artificielle avec
donneur
souvent on entend que pelephone se
traite ce qui pour avoir des enfants
ben disons la naissante plaisir à la
disparue assez vite parce qu'on a dû
inviter dans le projet intime de fonder
une famille
d'autres personnes comme c'était pas le
fourn des genres des médecins du travail
social des pharmaciens en plus de ça
ben moi j'ai dû affronter beaucoup de
porc comme par exemple depuis que
j'étais ado je n'avais pas des examens
gynécologiques
je peux vous dire qu'après plus que 40
examen gynécologique ma part est perçue
grâce à la désensibilisation une hauteur
que j'avais depuis aussi depuis je te
jure
c'était des opérations un moment donné
le sein est maudit
ça serait bien mais quand on perd
pourtant du mythe rio sava aiderez à
votre fertilité
même si j'avais par les opérations j'ai
dit oui tout de suite parce que ma part
de jammeh est une maman était beaucoup
plus grande que celle de l'opération en
soi en plus de toutes ces parle
en plus j'avais dépensé envahissante à
ce moment là j'avais pas encore de
diagnostic de troubles anxieux mais
disons que je m'en doutais pas mal mais
je me posais plein de questions comme le
fameux pourquoi moi je demandais qu'est
ce que je fait pas correct dans le fond
est ce que je prends trop de médicaments
ce qui a des conséquences sur mon corps
aux parents si j'en prends aussi
longtemps est ce que c'est juste pour
mon mari et moi je suis une maman
biologique pis pour lui
est-ce qu'on a enfin vaut bien vu avec
le fait d'avoir un troisième par an
invisible
je me posais beaucoup de questions je
pensais beaucoup d'ailleurs je recevais
souvent ce fameux conseil des gens
autour de moi arrête de penser là tu dis
pas trop c'est une mode in the sun mais
c'est dans le fond je n'avais pas
vraiment un choix dû penser un parce que
s'il fallait que j'aille à mirande et
vous fait je prenne congé palace et
rendez-vous la flèche prenne ma
médication
je subissais les effets de la médication
et je devais gérer mon budget pour
m'offrir toutes ces traitements l'a
d'ailleurs c'est plate que l'argent
ajoutant le stress de plus a tout appris
16 ainsi mination saint suaire où
j'espère être maman c'est soit bien où
j'ai pleuré quand j'ai eu mes règles
mais j'étais épuisé puis je suis allé
voir mon médecin
l'enfant mon rêve était plus vraiment un
brave l'interdît pas mal un cauchemar
clermont 20,5 me dis le à nyc
c'est fini les hormones la chute est
prescrit un voyage dans le sud
ça voulait dire repose toi j'avais
atteint mes limites et j'arrête trumer
traitement d'après ces traitements là
bas et je t'ai toujours autant motivé ma
main mais c'est sûr que j'étais fatigué
mais toujours aussi motivé avec mon mari
et moi on a choisi la voie de l'adoption
pour nous la d'options ça toujours été
un réel choix et non un choix de
rechange
on ne choisit d'adopter en colombie mais
on n'avait pas encore comment sont des
marches avant ce même comme je disais
qu'ils étaient les jours une choix mais
on n'avait pas commencé avant parce que
il manquait toujours un critère on était
toujours trop 60 est trop jeune trop
pauvre humaines pour certains pays
j'étais trop grosse c'est vrai bien en
2011 bien à ce moment alors on avait
vieilli un petit peu mais claude danis
type dans quelques pays et on a choisi
la colombie et on a choisi d'adopter une
fratrie parce qu'on se disait on sait
qu'on avait plusieurs a enfin fait que
tant qu'à y aller ça va valoir la peine
puis on s'est dit me sens que ça va être
rassurant pour eux d'arriver ensemble on
était sûr de cette décision là mais la
décision qu'on a vraiment plus hésiter
c'est sûr jusqu'à quel âge on était prêt
à adopter c'était quoi notre âge limite
pour faire un choix éclairé
j'ai lu plein de l'aivp rassure le
troubles de l'attachement
ensuite c'est vraiment heureux
un autre jour ce qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on a pu discuter que des paras qui
avait vécu cette expérience là puis nous
on vient vraiment exprimer comment qui
s'étaient sentis mais celles qui m'ont
convaincu c'est une petite fille pendant
une conférence pour parent adoptant
cette petite fille là elle avait adopté
de la colombie et savait seulement
quelques mois qui était adopté ben bella
comme d'être bien r parle bien français
quel autre vie que les grands vont enfin
aussi avait besoin de parents féclaz
c'est là que je me sens interpellé
je me suis dit moi je suis capable
d'être une maman comme ça et je me
sentais capable mais c'est sûr que j'ai
eus par ge pensent que si j'adopte et
mes enfants plus vieux bâ qui m'appelle
jamais maman ou qui m'aiment pas ou que
les gens autour de moi que c'est pas ma
décision
finalement les gens autour de mon super
bien acceptée sûr mais c'est certain que
des fois j'ai reçu des commentaires de
déjà qu'ils me connaissent pas beaucoup
et mandat d une modèle qui me regardait
pas le dire oh ouais il y en a qui
veulent tout certains ça veux pas salir
les mains ça veut pas changer de coach
et l'autre commentaires que j'ai plus
plus souvent c ou en laissant les vrais
parents des enfants à l'eau c'est comme
si moi je sens une fausse mère à caudry
et puis 6 touaffeck en adoptant bon on
accepte beaucoup de choses comme moi
j'ai accepté que au fond de mon coeur
que mes enfants on aurait dit une maman
avant moi et j'ai accepté de ne pas tout
savoir leur histoire c'est moi je suis
la maman de mes enfants et je sais pas à
quel âge qui ont marché
je sais pas s'ils ont été arrêtés ou non
comme je disais tantôt je vais beaucoup
d'anxiété pendant les inséminations mais
pendant l'adoption le c'était vraiment
beaucoup plus encore et puis je pouvais
pas vraiment parler parce que je savais
que si j'en parle et ça peut nuire à mon
projet d'adoption savait pas au bout
dans un dossier de même ambitieux même
si j'ai accepté beaucoup de choses
il ya quand même des images j'ai choisi
de ne pas aller j'ai mis des limites
comme par exemple quand on adopte une
étape où on reçoit
booster dans le temps cette lettre qu'on
avait 90 critères que l'organisme
d'adoption nous demander de classe et de
celui où on se sent le plus à l'aise
jusqu'à salut qu on le sent plus vite ou
alex dans le fond des critères ça peut
être des maladies qu'ils ont enfin en ou
des situations qu'ils ont vécues chez
moi chez quelqu'un très ouvert d'esprit
mais en regardant saut je me sentis
coupables parce que des choses que je me
dis je serais pas capable ça j'ai eu de
la misère arrive avec son petit bout de
temps malgré que j'aille me ses limites
là mais moi j'ai eu la chance qu'on me
propose un dossier
j'ai pu adopter une grande fille de 9
ans et un petit garçon de 7 ans et je
partage la photo de notre première
rencontre alors 6 à son bord trois ans
après l'adoption de mes enfants
mais j'en voulais un autre savais pas si
c'était d'ouvrir mon coeur fait que j'en
voulais un autre et j'ai fait un beau
rêve d'un petit bébé qui est venu me
voir dans mon sommeil qui m'a dit
bonjour maman je m'en viens bientôt je
m'appelle laurence et le moi j'écoutais
ce rêve là je les aime entre hommes puis
on a décidé d'aller maintenant vers la
fécondation in vitro avec donneur au
départ moi j'avais un petit peu de
misère avec cette méthode là parce que
je trouvais qu'on forçait un petit peu
trop la nature on dirait que c'est un
petit malaise avec ça j'en ai parlé avec
plusieurs personnes
puis on m'a donné un nadal tu m'as dit
ces années clore les césariennes pas
très naturel on est bien content que ça
existe
là j'ai fait boire c'est vrai qu'on est
privilégié de vivre dans un pays une
époque où c'est possible qu'on a accès à
ce fait que moi j'étais dans ce chemin
et l'eau de la fécondation in vitro
ça a vraiment bien été et deux petites
choses que j'ai trouvé plus difficile ça
a été la réaction des hormones que je
devais même pas à la maison
d'ailleurs j'ai jamais réussi sûr c'est
toujours mon autre chose qu il le fait
et aussi la fonction des ovocytes que ça
fait mal
alors j'étais vraiment chanceuse parce
que moi ça a fonctionné du premier coup
et j'ai une belle grossistes le temps
pleine forme et j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer vraiment ma petite fille que
j'ai appelé laurence dors plus
aujourd'hui c'est certain je suis fier
du chemin que j'ai parcouru pour avoir
mes enfants mais je très consciente que
des fois j'ai failli dépasser mes
limites
dernièrement je suis tombé sur une
station nelson mandela qu que je trouve
qu'ils représentent bien mon histoire
c'est que vos choix reflètent vos
espoirs et novo par mois j'ai eu par
toulon mais j'avais plus mon rêve des
plus grands que sur il se termine en vue
partagé une phrase que mon petit
bonhomme maudit quand j'étais petit
loyer plus petits c'est que ça me donne
quand j'entends ce j'entends cette
phrase là je me suis dit j'ai eu raison
de croire qu'une famille c'est plus que
des liens de sang sa face et même en les
portant spot se ressembler et d'avoir le
petit filet lisible qui relie nos coeurs
merci
[Applaudissements]